il est le premier au commissaire de
l'ONU à se rendre en Ukraine depuis le
début de l'invasion russe une visite
qu'il ne risque pas d'oublier au
lendemain de son arrivée à Kiev Walker
turc a dû se réfugier dans un abri
souterrain de la capitale après le
retentissement des sirènes
il y a eu une vague de missiles contre
l'Ukraine certains de ses missiles se
sont abattus à proximité de Kiev vous
pouvez imaginer ce que vit la population
c'est presque devenu normal ici mais
cela a un impact énorme sur les civils
cela doit s'arrêter
akief tout son désormais le même réflexe
plus de 9 mois après le début de la
guerre se réfugier dans le métro à
chaque menace de frappe russe ce lundi
plus de 70 missiles ont été tirés à
travers le pays 60 auraient été détruit
par les forces entières Yann ukrainienne
je veux remercier les forces de défense
anti-aérienne nos ingénieurs en énergie
et notre peuple la défense anti-aérienne
a abattu la plupart des missiles les
ingénieurs en énergie ont déjà commencé
à rétablir l'électricité notre peuple
n'abandonne jamais gloire à l'Ukraine
l'électricité qui est en est privé à 40%
après ces frappes d'après l'opérateur
électrique ukrainien toutes les régions
du pays doivent mettre en place des
coupures de courant pour maintenir
l'équilibre entre la production et la
consommation d'électricité pour la
Russie l'objectif est simple viser un
maximum d'infrastructures énergétiques
afin de réduire les capacités de combats
de l'Ukraine alors que le froid hivernal
commence à s'installer dans tout le pays